je voudrais remercier
le dernier intervenant parce que la voix
qu'il a portées et les plus importantes
que vous imaginez nous nous adressons
aux français à tous les français sans
distinction d'origine de couleur de peau
de passe et d'engagement politique dans
le passé et c'est une grande richesse
que vous ai dit ce que vous avez à dire
et je lis ça à la précédente
intervenantes qui rythment alors on
nettoie ton n'est pas droite on est de
droite
on n'est pas simplement de droite on
porte les racines de la france dans leur
diversité
donc vous êtes vraiment quelqu'un qui
apporte conseil national la preuve que
les républicains c'est une formation
politique qui s'adresse à toute la
nation
alors il ya un avis que la gironde
j'ai vu que sa question à l'aide
difficile puisqu'il a commencé à dire
que j'avais des qualités c'est en
général avant la suite et qu'il allait
mettre le trouble
cher alain je me suis demandé la jeune
sétois
s'élançant
il pose la question du modèle j'ai voulu
ce débat libre en présence des
journalistes
nous n'avons rien à cacher d'abord qu'il
me soit permis de revenir sur notre
stratégie pour les régionales comme pour
les départementales on en a parlé entre
nous j'ai voulu et j'assume l'alliance
avec lui dit et le centre ça pas été si
facile
il ya un certain nombre d'entre vous qui
nous en ont voulu
je veux rendre hommage à alain joyandet
à guillaume pelletier à trois qui
auraient parfaitement pu être tête de
liste dans leur région je parle de la
normandie françoise je parle de la
franche comté la bourgogne
je parle du centre je leur ai demandé
c'est vrai ou pas de renoncer ils l'ont
accepté mais vous êtes parlement du
mouvement
est-ce qu'on aurait gagné dans le nord
pas de calais est ce qu'on aurait gagné
en provence alpes côte d'azur
est-ce qu'on aurait gagné ailleurs si on
avait dû affronter une liste de l'uni y
compris en ile de france
j'assume le choix de l'alliance avec les
centristes
c'était la seule solution et je le dis
de la même façon je me battrai pour que
lui dit est un accord législatif avec
nous est connue des participants aux
primaires alors à l'intérieur du centre
yalu dei avec qui nous avons gouverné ya
le modèle eia bayrou
je ne suis pas spécialiste mais c'est
pas tout à fait la même chose
d'abord il y a des élus des militants et
des électeurs du modem qui ont voté pour
nos listes et qui ont participé à nos
listes avec une loyauté sur laquelle je
n'ai rien à dire et je pense notamment à
l'île de france
s'agissant de l'aquitaine et du poitou
charentes et du limousin
virginie calmels a fait un combat
remarquable et elle a fait honneur aux
républicains tout le temps me dis il
faut des nouveaux il faut des femmes est
naturellement quand on trouve des
nouveaux spécialement club c'est des
femmes l'on trouve toujours quelque
chose
permettez moi de vous dire contre
virginie calmels et maud fontenoy
on a deux personnes courageuses qui
renouvelle profondément l'image de la
vie politique de notre mouvement est ce
que je souhaite pour nous c'est beaucoup
de femmes comme r s'agissant de monsieur
bayrou ya un débat entre nous faut pas
le cacher va pas se mentir
moi je pense que monsieur bayrou vote à
gauche pas depuis 2002 depuis bien avant
je pense qu'il a voté à gauche en 2002
je n'ai pas entendu soutenir monsieur
chirac avec une force considérable
je pense qu'il a voté à gauche en 2007
en tout cas lors de mon élection son
soutien ne m'a pas honorer et ne m'a
d'ailleurs pas empêché d'être élu
quant à 2012 il a mis tout son espérance
dont françois hollande
on peut pas lui reprocher ça la question
du débat que nous auront à trancher est
ce que nous avons intérêt à ce que
monsieur bayrou soit candidat à la
présidentielle parce qu'ils piquent des
voix au candidat socialiste ou est-ce
que nous avons intérêt à ce qu'il soit
avec nous moi je pense qu'à la minute où
fait un accord avec monsieur bayrou ya
une grande partie des électeurs qui sont
les nôtres qui disent on a compris
ils ne feront pas la politique sur
laquelle ils s'engagent parce que ya
monsieur bayrou
je dis pas que j'ai la vérité gens bien
je dis que c'est mon opinion je dis
d'ailleurs aussi que compte tenu de ce
que furent ces choix constant en faveur
de la gauche
s'il est candidat au premier tour la
présidentielle il prendra plus de voix
au candidat socialiste ou au candidat
qui sortira des primaires de la droite
et du centre
mais nous aurons à débattre de cela
c'est un débat médiocre et voyez les
journalistes sont là moi j'ai vu le
front national ils se réunissent à 80
dans un hôtel dont ils ferment les
portes nous on se réunit à 2000 ici
porte de versailles avec les
journalistes cassis à notre débat et ce
n'est pas mes chers amis et j'aimerais
tellement pour re partie de ce conseil
national en vous disant ils sont pas
d'accord sur tout mais ils sont capables
d'exprimer leurs divergences en restant
dans la même salle et un habitant dans
la même famille je le dis en saluant la
présence comme je lé fais tout à l'heure
dans la jupe et de jean pierre raffarin
de jean françois copé et de tous ceux
qui participent à ce débat avec françois
fillon cet après midi 6 à une famille
politique qui a la capacité d'incarner
l'alternance